the
quantitative easing era monetary policy
you were around when volcker didn't care
about the markets
and it was a much different kind of a
relationship between wall street
and and the federal reserve how has that
influence
in your view historically speaking
changed and
more importantly can the fed ever stop
we've been told in the last few months
that qe
is now official tool in the toolbox and
that they will be using
it on a regular basis and i think the
market has
priced in that they're never ever going
to exit
you know one of biden's potentials was
to dig up off the bearings
who vocal worked london by the way uh
when he was head of new york
market is addicted to
the fed okay we were addicted to some
degree to buybacks but the liquidity
issue and
the product is in there i don't think
you could make a good case
that if they didn't do what they did
to that during covert we would have
these kind of markets i think would have
been a lot more
damage out there significant damage
whether you're measured by unemployment
companies whatever it is so pretty
positive could they have done better
historians will go back and say yes or
no but we have gotten addicted to that
and the fed has uh
signals that this will continue for a
while so the market has this built into
every spreadsheet uh no one's looking
for the uh the tenure to go back to 16
jimmy carter times
now you know 1.6 maybe you'll see on a
couple of longer term ones not even
next year or the year after uh so yes
the market
is basing these in uh that liquidity is
there
financing is is is in there uh
and that you will buy anything uh out
there
that is broadly considered fixed income
regardless of how it's classified 40
years of low interest rates
every once in a while in history it's
rare but every once in a while
the market the market takes off and and
does its own bidding
i mean theoretically there's a bond
vigilante left somewhere there i mean
they can't all be dead what would
interest rates
being taken out of the control of the
fed long long maturity
what would rising interest rates how
would that factor into
the market today because there's a lot
of chat about
the potential for for the bond market
to divorce itself from monetary policy
that's that's just the chatter on the
street that we're going to be in a
rising interest rate regime that we're
going to have
fiscal spending as far as the eye can
see and
that at some point uh we we're that the
fed's going to lose control
obviously higher deficits and yes
inflation will eventually come back uh
not to the hopefully the uh carter times
but you know to where it's
well above that uh anywhere near two
percent range
on but as far as the market goes
okay right now we've got short term
you've got the numbers so you
so you assume that going forward one of
the scenarios one of the branches
much higher spending uh potentially
balling through the
creation on there the expense on the
on corporations again we're looking from
the market perspective
okay higher interest rates but we are so
far down compared to it was five or ten
years ago
these numbers are significantly down
even with higher
debt okay i mean a lot of members of
what when
companies try to refinance they've got
to buy
bonds that are a much higher you know
calling them in on there you haven't
seen that since the 80s
you know jenny mays and those
so yes higher interest rates will hurt
the companies but also put money back if
we get a general increase
all those investors mentioned going into
cds and there's
a lot of money sitting on the side it
does not go into stock they're going to
get at least
some more income in there corporations
have enough
sufficient cash on hand access to
liquidity
and in general cash flow cash flow is
not what it was
okay earnings are not what they want
especially when you do a cash flow
remember a lot of these charges
were non-cash it's a paper charge it's
going to change your depreciation it's
going to change your gap numbers
but the cash flow is different on there
okay so the companies on next several
years even if we get
higher interest expense uh
we're going to have more stimulus and
they should more than compensate for
that
from a market point of view again uh
inflation farther down
higher interest rates down how you pay
for the deficit
uh how you how those bonds are maturing
okay if all of a sudden it's not point
something but
you know what's high numbers very valid
and if you were to do this for a 20
30 year it's an enormous and one i think
you put it on your top list of concerns
for the economy
uh looking at the debt levels whether
you want to do it as a percentage of gpp
gdp whether you want to do prop whatever
you want to do
the average cost of capital to the
government
with the debt going up as well expected
to go up more
is going to be a problem uh shorter term
is a different situation and the market
obviously is a different
interpretation
[Music]